hey guys ryan right here i'm dan savard
and uh recently a trailer has been
released for a game that people are
sort of raving about i'm excited for it
it's called battleborn one word it's not
the album by the killers that's what i
learned
yeah i i've only like read the synopsis
on this uh cool synopsis last star or
some [ __ ] happening bad guys closing in
got to work with other people ign.com
people developer gearbox so pumped for
that i love borderlands borderlands 1
borderlands 2 they got the borderlands
the prequel sequel that's coming out
here soon and now this
so i'm pumped i'm i i i i pumped myself
up earlier
you know well i've now i'm kind of
relaxed
youporn.com
oh yeah okay yeah that's why i'm so calm
today i really wanted to
just feel on my most natural leaves all
right take a shower afterwards okay
thank you
may contain content
looks like avatar oh dude
whoa
wow
wow that's pretty cool
damn
oh man
[ __ ] with the wrong [ __ ] oh love the
hat it's a cash huge
they're just gonna [ __ ] up some [ __ ]
aren't they oh [ __ ] they're going for it
my
captain america
oh my god this is great
how [ __ ] cool
it's a co-op right yeah
oh
dude
that looks pretty [ __ ] heroically
epic
i dig it i dig it a lot yeah that looks
really cool dude it's really cool see
like gearbox because i saw that that
beetle in the very beginning i'm like if
i know gearbox something's gonna step on
that and cue
you know quirky punchline but that was
no that was like some serious heavy [ __ ]
like yeah i found myself concerned for
that girl for some reason really early
on
when she got blown i was like oh no
but then mr peanut
mr peanut showed up and everything was
fine it didn't really look like a
robotic version of it it did but it
still looks pretty bad i'm still pretty
cool with this like shotgun umbrella or
whatever he's wearing yeah oh my god no
yeah that does look really [ __ ] cool
it's like a collection of a lot of
different things that we've sort of seen
before but it's a new look to it as well
i'm really excited for it actually yeah
i mean if borderlands has taught me
anything about the guys over at gearbox
is that they know how to put the story
together and they know how to do
something rather unique and this looks
different an idea
different in a very familiar way though
it's kind of hard to describe yeah
that's sort of what i was trying to say
yeah
it's like it's different i'm familiar
with it and i'm on board with it i just
don't know like it's just different yeah
yeah it's kind of got it's like
hyrule meets halo
this man yeah i can't wait for like a
gameplay trailer on it yeah i really
want to see more like i want to see how
they're going to like build all these
characters up and what it's going to be
like i can see that being a really
popular pc game it's coming out like on
all the systems
yeah you have xbox one ps4 pc yeah
that's pretty much all you need
for wii u oh boy
i just want to give nintendo a hug
it's for
nintendo for you buddy anyway guys um
this
you
thanks for uh not recommending that dan
told me about it
no one's recommended it yet we beat you
to the punch if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe right here and
if you want to subscribe to dan's gaming
channel that cyber channel right here
fun fact dan's last name is really
cybert but it's not spelled like this no
no
it's spelled s
y
eventually he'll figure it out uh dan do
you remember what time of the video it
is
it's shout out time shout out time to
shout
he said shout out
that was it
you know what that is demanding
it's too imperative you uh have to at
least put a question mark it's a little
bit rude what if he missed
he went the exact opposite way up the
keyboard
he's like
he's got a picture of a
anime character with an eye kakashi that
is kakashi that's gakashi asi smart i am
a nerd i am
i am a geek
i know these things meanwhile guy over
here who just improperly identified him
all right
yeah kakashi uh good for you to name
yourself after such a respectable
character
how can you tell it was kakashi just
from that um i was giveaway yeah the eye
because he's got a scar and oh she's got
the scar i watched her i watched naruto
back
skylar seasons hello he said can i have
a shout out please because i love your
videos and i watch every day skyler did
you draw your thumbnail it looks like a
uh
handicapped version of a lego character
you know um
she'll kill me for saying this
but i once knew a girl named skyler we
fooled around a few times
am i gonna die
okay
huge boobs
you were dead
i won't say her last name could be
another skyler who knows how many
skylers i don't know a single skyler
yeah well i know plenty
one of them has huge knockers
all right well so if you have huge
knockers you better contact me
skylar if you want to hit them
go for it which guy are you talking to
either oh well skylar seasons you are
the accumulation of all four seasons
you are my year
i love you that's pretty deep man oh but
yeah that was tender not big boob skyler
uh i mean you're all right but
skylar season
anthony tanza what's up you guys are
awesome thanks is there any chance that
i could get a shout out to yeah
let me reach into my chance pocket over
here
what do you know
it's anthony tarza
can i say your chance
status real quick here you go
awesome oh go directly to jail oh son of
a [ __ ]
too bad monopoly jokes
you got it you got it anthony is my
brother's name so
um
i guess i like you i have respects for
anthony are you do you also go by tony
oh or t-man
that wouldn't make sense why do you go
by t-man he enjoys green tea ah a.t
you're just like oh man there's there's
team man enjoying some green tea again
that [ __ ] got honey sucked please
comment down below if it had honey
tarza or tanza tan
tanza tanza sorry man your initials are
80
backwards that's tits and ass
oh my god he's close to tony danza
are you tony dancer you're tony tanza
yeah
i'm sure you haven't heard that like 80
times it doesn't matter you gotta hear
it one more time tony tanza tony tanza
tony tanza also you're awesome oh yeah
that too
hold me closer tony tanza